LITTLE FUN. WE'RE GOING TO
ALL-TIME NFL, PRESS E
CONFERENCES MILES. I'LL GIVE
YOU THE HONORS. OKAY. WELL
THIS ONE COMES
IT'S FROM DEREK ANDERSON. WHO
WAS A QUARTERBACK THAT I
WATCHED GROWING UP WITH THE
BROWNS, HE WAS REALLY WELL,
THE ONLY QUARTERBACKS WHO HAD
A GOOD SEASON WITH THE
GROUNDS WHEN I WAS YOUNG IN
2007, BUT WHEN HE WENT TO THE
ARIZONA CARDINALS, HE PLAYED
ON A MONDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL
GAME AND THE C
AS CAUGHT
HIM LAUGHING ON THE SIDELINES.
AND AFTER THE GAME HE HAD A
LAUGHING ON THE SIDELINES AND
AFTER THE GAME HE HAD A VERY
INTERESTING REACTION TO BEING
QUESTIONED ABOUT IT. I THINK
IT'S FUNNY. I THINK SERIOUS,
I'M NOT I'M REAL SERIOUS. I
PUT MY HEART AND SOUL INTO
THIS EVERY SINGLE WEEK. ALL,
I'M SAYING IS THE CAMERA SHOW.
JUST TELLING YOU RIGHT NOW
WHAT I DO EVERY SINGLE WEEK
EVERY SINGLE WEEK, I PUT MY
FREAKIN HEART AND SOUL INTO
THIS. I STUDY MY ASS OFF. I
GO OUT THERE AND LAUGHED.
IT'S NOT FUNNY IT'S NOT FOR
NOTHING IS FUNNY TO ME. I
DON'T WANT TO GO OUT THERE
IT'S NOT FOR NOTHING IS FUNNY
TO ME. I DON'T WANT TO GO OUT
GO OUT THERE AND GET
EMBARRASSED ON MONDAY NIGHT
FOOTBALL IN FRONT OF
EVERYBODY. THAT WAS GOOD THAT
WAS VERY GOOD AND I REMEMBER
THAT, I REMEMBER THE NIGHT
THAT HAPPENED GUY'S INTENSE,
I'VE HAD TO MUTE HIM ON
TWITTER, HE CAME AT ME A
COUPLE TIMES AND THE BEST
APPROACH IN SITUATIONS LIKE
THAT, IS THAT, THAT MUTE THAT
MUTE BUTTON IS POWERFUL
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW,
THEY DON'T KNOW THAT YOU DON'T
DON'T SEE WHAT THEY'RE SAYING.
THEY CAN SAY WHATEVER THEY
SOCIAL MEDIA, LALALA NOT
LISTENING. I LOVE IT.
ALL RIGHT, THIS ONE IS
EXTREMELY OBSCURE. IT HAS
NEVER BEEN APPRECIATED THE
WAY THAT IT SHOULD. I TAKE
YOU BACK TO THE LATE 80S,
POSSIBLY THE EARLY 90S, THERE
WAS A GUY NAMED JERRY BURNS.
WHO WAS THE HEAD COACH OF
THE MINNESOTA VIKINGS? HE'S
ALIVE. I THINK WE USED TO
CALL HIM BEDHEAD BERNZY.
AMONG OUR UNOFFICIAL GROUP
OF VIKINGS FANS, BECAUSE HE
ALWAYS LOOKED LIKE HE HAD
ROLLED RIGHT OUT OF BED.
HE IS CURSING LIKE A SAILOR.
ROLL THE FOOTAGE. I DON'T
LIKE THE NAME NAMES IF YOU
THROW A F****** GAME BUT WE
CAN'T, WE CAN'T BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE BLACK AND
WE CAN'T BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
IT GUYS. JUMPING OFF SIDE. WE
CAN'T BE RESPONSIBLE FOR. WE
GET DOWN THERE AND IT WAS A
DUMB PLAY BY ANDERSON. I LOVE,
I LOVE ANDERSON BUT IT WAS A
DUMB F****** PLAY WHEN HE
HAD WITH HIS FOOT WAS SHE WAS
COMING OFF UP THE LINE
SCREEN. WE WERE HIRING TAKE
TIME OUT. WE HAD A TRAP PLAY
CALLED
AND HE AND HIS SHOE COMES OFF.
THAT'S JUST PART OF IT. GO TO
IN. JERRY BURNS JERRY WITH A
J-JUST LIKE SEINFELD AND YOU
WILL GET TO ENJOY THE FULL
THING AND YOU THERE'S A
RABBIT HOLE OUT THERE OF SOME
COACH INTERACTIONS WITH
REPORTERS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
WIDELY APPRECIATED, JIM MOORE
HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN A COUPLE
SHOCKINGLY. HE'S GOT A COUPLE
OF THE ALL-TIME GREAT PRESS
CONFERENCES, THAT WE OMITTED,
BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN THEM,
WE'VE APPRECIATED THEM. BUT
JERRY BURNS. JUST
BEAUTIFUL STUFF.
I HAD NO IDEA HE HAD THAT
SIDE TO HIM BECAUSE NOBODY
REALLY PAID ATTENTION, IT WAS
IT WAS YOU KNOW YOU DIDN'T
KNOW HE WAS THAT FIERY VERY
FAR IF YOU WATCHED THAT WHOLE
VIDEO. IMAGINE IF A HEAD
COACH STARTED DOING THAT
TODAY MAN RIGHT AFTER A GAME
NOTHING GETS STREAMED E
EVERYWHERE. ALL THESE TEAMS
JUST STREAM THERE PRESS
CONFERENCES. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY WOULD DO IT. HIT
THE LIVE. YOU, OH MY GOD. CUT
HIM OFF, CUT THEM OFF, BE
FANTASTIC.
YEAH, AND THAT'S RIGHT. IT'S
NOT LIKE YOU CAN, YOU CAN DO
THE LIVE SEVEN-SECOND DELAY
THAT NEVER WORKS. I DON'T
CARE HOW GOOD YOU ARE,
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE'S GOING
MACHINE GUN, F-BOMB, YOU JUST
KEEP YOUR FINGER ON THAT
BUTTON UNTIL HE STOPS TALKING.
THE WHOLE THING'S BLEEPED.
IT'S WORSE THAN SIMS FOR
CRYING OUT LOUD. ALL RIGHT